the five foot six safety came into the
game with division 3 Shenandoah up 26
points against Juniata College
registering a quarterback hurry on the
way to a Shenandoah win did that
quarterback know what or who hit him
I've had some people come up to after
the game until I take my helmet off
they're like dude I didn't know you were
even a girl I mean this woman just ran
at him totally unblocked and for some
reason decided to cling on to him long
after he threw the ball to his receiver
and eventually after a couple seconds
she drags him to the turf almost like
it's happening in slow motion now in any
other context if you don't know anything
about football what you saw in that play
there that is a roughing the passer
penalty worth 15 yards